[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pris du poids de la villardière un peu
c'est vraiment le temps que tous ces
voyages c'est vrai que j'ai ce qu'on dit
et voyages forment la jeunesse
dis donc qu'est ce que c'est que ça
donne à bakwa c'est dans mes gènes je
peux pas arrêter tu m'avais promis
d'arrêter je ne peux pas reste que tu me
coûte en huile de jojoba au point qu'ils
écoulent mon stock
allez pas fait ma minouche le nouveau
resto mia viatique mes talents des
femmes
saloperie ben oui mais ça ne fonctionne
pas ça ne fonctionne pas puisque je pige
pas quoi au badge et je suis en train de
regarder la dise quoi la minute put your
remote on the side and press the button
mais ça veut dire quoi appuyer sur un
bouton mais bon que ça des boutons à
quelques dix après l'icône the side and
shake gym tout et ça veut dire quoi ça
ça veut dire qu'apparemment ils font il
faut envoyer un chèque mais sous 15e et
mais il y met pas la grèce une force
finish expérience un greeter sense of
the spotless mind et ça ça veut dire
quoi à ça ça veut dire que tu m'emmerdes
et non pas aux lola vient d'un seul tube
à s'assurer n'a compris sa tata jamais
faux culs jamais
[Musique]
tac tac c'est qui ces gens gens qui gens
ne tient pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]